oh
foreign
thank you
great
sorry where is see it yeah thank you
uh
so
okay
okay
i don't know
so
um
no fault of their own needed relief
politics as usual should find no place
during this pandemic
but democrats rejected multiple clean
bills to provide relief
the american people are tired of games
they seek leadership
and president trump delivered this
weekend president trump took executive
action designed to provide
the relief democrats have denied to
those who need it most
through four executive orders he took
the following step steps
on the payroll tax he deferred payments
of the employee portion of certain
payroll taxes from september first
through the end of 2020 on unemployment
assistance states will provide 25
cost sharing amounting to a total of 400
per week
and benefits through the end of the year
and then
third he extended the eviction uh
protections um president trump will
direct hud to prevent
evictions resulting from financial
hardships caused
by the virus doing everything in his
executive capacity
to make sure those renting and those
homeowners are protected
finally on student loans he extended
zero percent interest and suspended
loan payments through the end of the
year the bottom line is that these
actions will help americans president
trump is for the american people and
democrats failed to deliver
also earlier this year hundreds of
americans working
men and women at the tennessee valley
authority the tva were told that they
would lose
their jobs to lower paid foreign workers
imported from abroad
and then suffered the further indignity
of training their foreign replacements
president trump boldly and resolutely
intervened in defense of these
hard-working americans
rallying to their case rushing to their
aid and taking action to restore
their jobs he invited laid off workers
and their representatives to the white
house and then he fired the chairman of
the board of the tva and one other board
member
president trump offered an ultimatum the
firings would continue until the cruel
and heartless decision to fire
the hard working americans was reversed
tva did reverse layoffs have been
canceled and tech workers have been
rehired
in the words of gay henson president of
the engineering associates ifpte
local 1937 the labor union representing
the two
of the 2200 highly skilled professionals
employed by the tva
uh in miss henson's words the
president's personal intervention
saved these jobs restored the workers to
their rightful place
and set tva on the path to returning to
its mission of service to both the
workers
at the tva and to the people of this
country and with that i'll take
questions
yes haley thank you starting right there
with the president's actions over the
weekend
how quickly can americans expect to see
that extra 400 of unemployment insurance
so we hope to see it quickly um and
close to immediately i don't have an
exact readout for you on time but a lot
of this will depend on states
um and them applying because as you know
it's 75
federal government um covering and 25
the states and they can use cares
funding or even existing unemployment
funds
for that 100 but it will require an
application process and given that part
of it is up to the states in the
application process is it possible that
there will be
a delay in that some individuals won't
see this relief at all
we will be working around the clock to
make sure there's not a delay
but any delay that does exist it's
important to note
where that delay and the responsibility
residence with nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer who they were offered a clean
extension not at 400
of unemployment uh benefits but 600
and it was roundly rejected by democrats
so this president
stood up for the american worker at a
time when democrats refused to do so
just to be very clear you're saying that
you're going to work around the clock
you wanted to get to americans quickly
are we talking weeks are we talking a
month can you pinpoint the timeline
i can't pinpoint a timeline other than
we'll be working around the clock and we
encourage democrats on the hill
uh to come back secretary mnuchin has
said he's willing to review
any proposal because the american people
deserve better than the games and the
partisanship they've seen from nancy
pelosi chuck schumer and their democrat
colleagues ben thanks kaylee two
questions just to follow up on what
kristen was asking is there a mechanism
by which the federal government can
provide the 300
immediately even if states don't provide
100.
well it's important in fact required by
statute
that 25 of that money be provided by
states and the 75
is what we can do from the federal
government side i would note states can
look to
cares act funding as a way to bring that
hundred dollars forward and they can
also look to the general fund
but we will be pursuing every creative
way possible to make sure
that the preeminent priority prevails
and that is making sure that this money
gets to america's workers
then the the orders of the president
sign that doesn't address funding for
small businesses
or for schools or stimulus checks does
he still want legislation to address all
of those things
and is he willing to negotiate with
democrats he absolutely would love to
see both of those things school funding
is very important
and he's been for second round of direct
payments
so we encourage democrats to really
negotiate with us in good faith so far
they have not done so
in fact moving further away from us
rather than towards us negotiations work
by coming towards one another
i mean it's incumbent upon democrats to
do that they say they've come down from
three trillion to two trillion is the
white house willing to go up from one to
something else
they've still put in several
non-starters they've never put forward a
serious proposal in the notion
um before they claimed to have come down
they actually went up
and then they wanted a 100 billion in
school funding we said okay we'll give
you more than you ask for 105 billion
to which was no longer acceptable so
they've been fundamentally on serious
with
each and every one of their uh their
offers in this negotiation
yes thank you a number of democrats but
also
republican senator ben sasse has
suggested these executive actions are
unconstitutional can you walk us through
what the white house is using as a legal
rationale for the president of stepping
in here and would you be able to share
those opinions yes um i
absolutely can do that um first i would
note that what we are doing is entirely
within the executive capacity
of the president on student loans
section
2a 2 subsection a of the higher
education relief opportunities for
student acts of 2003
which is 20 usc 1098 bb
authorizes the secretary to waive or
modify provisions of student financial
assistance programs
to ensure that individuals who've been
affected by the national emergency are
not worse off financially there's
another statute for that one section 432
of the higher education act of 1965
which gives broad authority to the
secretary
on unemployment the stafford act 42 usc
5174 says the president after a state
applies for it
can provide assistance to people who
have been adversely affected by
by a major disaster these are often
known as other needs assistance
or ona on payroll tax authority
26 usc 7508a plainly authorizes the
treasury secretary
to provide any taxpayer that has been
affected by federally declared disaster
with an extension of up to a year this
was used before
when the secretary extended the
individual filing deadline
for 2019 taxes from april to july and
finally
for evictions the authority would be
suggesting that hhs and hud consider
whatever legal authorities they have
to protect americans uh and also
the president merely instructed in that
eo uh that we should do everything
within the lawful capacity of the
executive branch to protect
americans from evictions yes definitely
on china
is the administration planning to
respond to the new sanctions that china
announced this morning on several
lawmakers and other people in the united
states
so i won't get ahead of the president on
any actions
but we are certainly aware of the
announced sanctions um and instead of
taking meaningful actions such as
immediately repealing the national
security law
and stopping the system the systematic
repression of uyghurs the chinese
communist party opted to respond with
the symbolic
and ineffectual action and a growing
number of nations around the globe are
demanding real action
from beijing the ball is in the chinese
communist party's court um this
president
has stood strongly against china and
he'll continue to do so is there any
discussion kaylee would be listing
chinese companies on the u.s exchange
again i won't
get ahead of the president on any
official announcements thank you the
president said over the weekend that he
had heard from democrats about
uh wanting to restart these negotiations
who exactly did he hear from and then
also his tweet this morning uh regarding
he said that he has
uh he said that leader uh schumer and
speaker pelosi had his number
in regarding regarding negotiations uh
does that mean he
is going to play a larger role in this
process going forward or is it still
going to be secretary mnuchin and the
chief of staff
well they speak on the president's
behalf he's been actively engaged in the
negotiations and working closely with
secretary mnuchin and the chief of staff
democrats should come to the table um
their immediate statement um in the
aftermath
of the president issuing these eos um
says that they would like to meet
halfway but
you know those are empty words from
democrats that they'd like to meet
halfway because so far they've just gone
in the other direction
did anybody reach out to him i'm not
going to go through the president's call
log so you guys can ask him
later today if you'd like he'll have a
press briefing at about 5 30.
jeff thank you kaylee secretary pompeo
has raised the issue of
russia bounties on u.s soldiers in
afghanistan with this
does that mean that the administration
now considers the intelligence on this
uh secure or or clear and if so
does the president plan to raise it with
president putin yeah so on
the part about secretary pompeo i'd
refer you to the state department that
was a new york times story so
in terms of his personal con
conversations i would refer you there
but on the part of the president he this
was unverified
not conclusory as the new york times
initially reported
um the president will always act in the
interests of our troops and
look no further than the killing of
solomonia in al-baghdadi which
brought vindication to hundreds of u.s
servicemen and women who lost their
lives overseas just to be clear does
that mean that
you did pompeo did not raise this does
that mean that i would refer you to the
state department but are the two sides
seeing this administrating that
intelligence is different here
and the state department again you're
asking me to verify reporting that would
be in the realm of the state department
but
rest assured this president will always
act in the best interest of our troops
yes thanks kaylee back on the executive
orders the president's time this weekend
as a candidate donald trump criticized
fairly sharply uh
barack obama's use of executive orders
and faulting him for
failing to reach deals with members of
congress how are the president's actions
this weekend
any different from president obama's
you're a lot different when you consider
the fact that
president barack obama utilized
executive order uh to push forward a
policy
um that he denied he had the right to
push forward 23 times on dapa and on
daca he said
at least 23 times i don't have the power
to do this and then he went on to do
just that i've
already listed out and enumerated the
various legal authorities on the part of
the president and in terms of
deal-making
i would note that the cares act was
landmark legislation
you know at the heat at really the
height of this pandemic that brought
relief to the american people and that
was negotiated
within one week from first drafting to
enactment
and by comparison if we want to go back
to president obama the american recovery
act during the great recession
took roughly three months from inception
to enactment as law under single party
control
this president managed to push the cares
act through divided government a very
big accomplishment on the part of the
president
yes kelly the deal that the president
announced late last month
with kodak to make new drugs
in the united states is apparently on
hold now amid
allegations of insider trading is the
president concerned
that his uh infrastructure here is being
misused
that the defense protection act funds
are are potentially being uh misused
would he pull the plug
on the kodak deal and what does it say
about the safeguards that you have in
place
that this potentially could have uh
resulted in insider trading so first the
president will always act in the best
interest of the american people
um as you noted as soon as we became
aware of these allegations the
international development finance
corporation
said that the recent allegations of
wrongdoing raise serious concerns
we will not proceed any further unless
these allegations are cleared
uh the president has strong faith in the
process here we've used the dpa more
than 30 times
to increase production i mean it's been
to great effect when you consider in the
stockpile we've seen
vast increases tripling the amount of
n95s tripling the number of gowns four
times
the number of ventilators on hand at
sixty nine thousand and we'll have more
than
ten thousand ten thousand more uh by the
fall so this president
has used the dpa effectively but we're
certainly aware of the kodak
allegations and take them seriously what
do you pull the plugs on that deal i'll
leave that to the president but he takes
these very seriously we won't speculate
as to what that investigation finds
thank you oh
two questions for me um the president
just tweeted that gettysburg would be
one of the two sides he's looking at
what can you characterize the message
that he'd want to be suspending with
that choice if it was that choice yeah i
won't get ahead of the president as to
what his convention speech will look
like
but the president has done a lot to
bring this country
together um we've faced unprecedented
challenges and
uh he's worked to make sure that the
american people are
are best equipped and taken care of to
rise above the challenges that we face
and
he has a strong record of achievement
that he'll be touting on that day
sorry there'd be other questions uh is
there a message to the protesters in
belarus is
is president looking at that is he
supporting them
yes so um we are looking at that and
we're deeply concerned by the belarus
presidential election severe
restrictions on ballot access for
candidates prohibition of local
independent observers at polling
stations
intimidation of opposition candidates
and the detention of peaceful protesters
and journalists have marred the process
and we urge the belarusian government to
respect the right of peace
to peaceably assemble and to refrain uh
from use of force
yes thanks kaley um is the president
willing to
uh provide some aid for states and local
governments giving that
given that the administration's asking
states to pay for
a quarter of the national guard
assistance and now a quarter of the
unemployment benefits
yeah the president's always been clear
here that you know he
wants to support state and local
governments but only for cobit related
matters and he doesn't want to bail out
blue states that had structural problems
long before this so that's where
his priorities lie yes all right i have
two questions one from somebody who
can't be here today but first of all the
president also just tweeted
student athletes have been working too
hard for their season to be counseled so
does he
disagree with college's counseling
sports and how would he guarantee their
safety if games did go ahead
yes i spoke to the president in the oval
office about that just before walking
out here and he is
very much would like to see college
football
um safely resume their sport and as he
mentioned in that tweet
a lot of these college athletes you know
work their whole lives to get
you know four years um sometimes they're
redshirted an extra year if they're
lucky
they work their whole lives for this
moment and he'd like to see them have a
chance to live out their dreams
i had a question from um anthony leaker
the chronicle fashion guide
do you have any reaction to the
resignation of the prime minister and
cabinet
in lebanon yeah and the president's
aware of the situation but that was just
breaking as i came out so i have nothing
to add to that
other than our artists with the people
and those who lost their lives christian
thanks kaley two on the orders um is the
administration at all concerned that
funding the federal government's cost
share through fema
could leave the government underfunded
for
hurricane season um and then secondly on
the housing provisions i'm just curious
why did the president
extend the addiction moratorium as it
was outlining cares is that because it
was being
unconstitutional so on evictions
um so on evictions i would note that the
president took
four strong actions here and again the
eviction moratorium created
there was a temporary moratorium put in
place by the cares act so the president
did what he can within his executive
capacity and it was four-part taking all
lawful measures
to prevent residential evictions number
two instructing hhs and cdc
uh to measure to take measures to
temporarily prohibit residential
evictions
um on hud prioritizing federal fundings
that can be used
as financial assistance to struggling
renters and homeowners
and also hud working with its grantees
and partners um to ensure that
homeowners are not forced out
and with regard to hhs um as they
explore
uh their executive authority here um 42
usc 264-a
authorized authorizes the surgeon
general in consultation with the
secretary
to make and enforce such regulations as
is in his judgment
that are necessary to prevent the
introduction transmission or spread of
communicable diseases so it will be
within hhs hhhs's purview to determine
whether covid meets those standards and
it could go a long way in helping
americans
who face eviction and your second
question it was about fema
is there a concern that you know pulling
from the disaster funds could leave them
unprepared for
the rest of well really the worst part
of perfect season
yeah so there is that snapback provision
that if um
fema does get below a certain level that
that money will step back so that is
certainly a concern and we'll make sure
that two things happen that americans
get paid but also that there's enough
funding there
to safely go through hurricane season
thank you thank you very much two
questions
what do you like the white house would
like to see happening in lebanon right
now
next and this weekend the u.s reached
five million
uh corona virus cases in brazil one
hundred thousand there
as health care experts compares the
response from
both uh government what went wrong here
and there um so first with lebanon that
was your first question you know we're
monitoring the situation
closely as i've said our heart goes out
to the men and women who lost their
lives
it's an absolute tragedy and the
president participated in a virtual
conference with international leaders
to work closely in our international
response effort we are delivering aid to
the region and our deepest
condolences go out to the victims um
with regard to the u.s response to the
coronavirus we've done more testing than
any country in the world
um and we do identify more cases we do
have
after all the most testing as the
president has noted um
when you look at the us response the
therapeutics the beginning of this there
was no coronavirus test it was a novel
virus but we
immediately worked to get more than 100
emergency use authorizations to identify
uh various types of testing on
therapeutics there was
no therapeutic that we knew to work with
coba it was a novel virus but again this
president worked and there are more than
210 clinical trials on therapeutics and
we have dexamethasone and convalescent
plasma
from desevere and others and the vaccine
to be on pace to be
uh it completed by the end of the year
when ebola took four years to go to
completion
this president is securing a vaccine at
the fastest rate ever for a novel
pathogen so
this president has a really historic
coronavirus relief response that we're
happy to talk about the comparison
between brazilian daylight um so
going back to his question on hhs and
the executive order is there no real
solution then for people who may be
facing eviction
by the end of this month or early
september well there is a solution i've
mentioned the four things that we've
done
um and will continue to do but the real
solution
uh the holistic solution rests with
congress and nancy pelosi and chuck
schumer coming to the table
uh this president instructed his
administration to find every single way
possible
that without congressional democrats who
have been unrelenting
uh and lacking in any sort of care or
empathy for the american people at least
when it comes to their negotiating
tactics
if they're not going to act and care for
the american people he would so
uh he instructed this administration to
pursue every legal avenue available to
us without chuck and nancy
um and he's done just that and then i'll
let you know bye-bye
thanks haley uh just so that with the
president
bypassing democrat stalling with
stimulus bill as
we've been discussing this room um how
pressing
is it to actually have a next phase bill
because it seems
that the executive order and the three
memoranda that he just signed
really was kind of a wish list of items
he wanted to pass so
how motivated is the white house to
push for a next phase stimulus bill in
spite of what the nation says
yeah the white house is still motivated
you know the president would love to see
the direct payments to americans the
president would love to see
the school funding there are several
items that we'd like to see happen
um the more relief for the american
people and those in need in particular
the better
but this president you know has taken
action to alleviate
alleviate some of that burden uh but
make no mistake um there's still much
more that we'd like to accomplish but
that includes
having willing negotiating partners in
congress and so far
we have none on the in the democrat
party it seems
um and then finally one thing i want to
leave you guys with is that 18 days ago
mayor ted wheeler tweeted what i saw
last night in portland
was powerful in many ways i listened
heard and stood with protesters and i
saw what it means when the federal
government
unleashes paramilitary forces against
its own people
uh he in fact called our federal agents
paramilitary forces
and around this same time our federal
officers were facing rioters barricading
officers inside the courthouse trapping
officers inside
launching of commercial grade fireworks
a federal agent's hand was impaled by
planted nails
three officers were likely were at least
temporarily i should say
um blinded when a laser uh was put in
their eyes this has been an ongoing
tactic by the rioters
um that was 18 days ago when mayor
wheeler stood with the rioters um and
against the quote paramilitary
forces but just four days ago it appears
mayor wheeler had a change of heart
as uh local officers took over the
situation in portland and he
now i guess this is what he believes now
quote when you commit
arson with an accelerant in an attempt
to burn down a building that is occupied
occupied by people who you have
intentionally trapped inside you are not
demonstrating
you are attempting to commit murder uh
he could not be more right about that it
is a drastic change it took him 73 days
i suppose to come up with that
realization
and what we're seeing in portland with
six nights in a row
riots being declared on wednesday uh you
had
some of these rioters shining lasers and
officers eyes disabled
security cameras broke windows use
boards to barricade the doors and start
a fire with 20 sworn
officers and civilian employees inside
this is unacceptable and it
is encouraging to see that the liberal
mayor of portland finally seems to
realize that
thank you everyone